infinity war was nuts  but this one is going to be your finest  hour we're in the endgame you know that  I was wiped out 50% of all living  creatures these are the highest Sikhs  that the Avengers have ever faced this  is the fight of our lives this is good  work Steve  I know it is because I don't know what  I'm gonna do if it doesn't everything  you think marbles pulled every single  trick out of the bag  they actually saved the best stuff for  this morning this is the end of the  firework show the grand finale soit  aliens insane you just don't know what  to expect  they guarantee you there is no way  anybody could guess what's gonna happen  where's the Avengers we gotta finish  this  tickets on sale now  you